en otros bosques el trabajo terminaría
aquí el tronco Z la se vende a una
Aserradero y las ramas quedan
desperdigadas por el suelo pero en este
predio privado de topia en el estado
mexicano de Durango se aprovecha de cada
pedazo del árbol si no se tiene cuidado
con el manejo los servicios de los
desperdicios Pues igual en caso de un
incendio este el daño es mayor verdad
así está localizado tal vez dañe esta
parte aquí un arbolado pero no daña
aquella
estos montículos de ramas también sirven
para no erosionar el suelo y retener el
agua en una región que padece
frecuentemente de sequías exacerbadas
queda terminado Sí y vamos al siguiente
seguimos con el tronco a unos kilómetros
del Bosque en esa empresa del municipio
de Santiago Papasquiaro la palabra
desecho tampoco existe así tenemos la
Consigna El reto de cada vez más ir
buscando Qué hacer qué mayor valor
agregado dale a nuestros residuos en
este momento para nosotros este es
nuestro mejor aprovechamiento en efecto
aquí el aserrín es multipropósito en
2019 la fábrica se convirtió en la
primera empresa forestal mexicana en ser
totalmente autosuficiente
energéticamente gracias a una Caldera de
bioenergía que carbura con residuos de
madera que no trabajamos aquí no se
calienta nada ahora nada ahí adentro
pero el aprovechamiento de estos
desechos no paraáis esta ceniza le hemos
hecho análisis químicos para utilizarla
como complemento a nuestro sustrato para
la producción de planta
con residuos de otras áreas de la
empresa forma un compost que se utiliza
para la reforestación pero no solamente
al lado de la fábrica también se
cultivaba orgullosamente maíz
y con este tipo de fertilizante
básicamente se han desarrollado esta
esta planta y aquí podemos ver que ya
tiene un elote
quizás buenas prácticas llevaron el
estado a tener el 47% de la superficie
forestal certificada del país bajo
estándares internacionales del Forest to
workship cancel los cuales garantizan
que se aprovecha la madera sin dañar el
bosque